i still to this day
i think uh well first the second time i
talked to joe rogan on this podcast
i said we got into this heated argument
about whether a
sense of a woman is a better movie than
john wick
because it's one of my favorite movies
for many reasons one is for sensible
women some scent of a woman uh partially
know that by the way it's just you just
yeah i don't know if you would actually
know awesome awesome yeah yeah i said i
love the tango scene i love al pacino's
performance
it's a wonderful movie
then joe joe was saying john wick is
better so we to this day argue about
this i think it depends in on what
conscious state you're in yes that you
would be ready and receptive to but um
sense of woman i think it has one of the
best monologues at the end of the movie
that has ever been written or at least
performed when al pacino
defends the
younger
yeah i
uh
i often think about that there's been
times in my life
i don't know about you
where i wish i had an al pacino in my
life
where
um
integrity is really important in this
life it is and sometimes you find
yourself in places where
there's pressure to sacrifice that
integrity
and you you want uh what is it
lieutenant colonel or whatever he was
late
come in uh on your side and and scream
at everyone and say what the hell are we
doing here
being you know unfortunately
british and sort of having that slightly
um
awkward sort of huge grant gene it's
it's very very
at the opposite end of the spectrum of
the remarkable feat of uh al pacino at
the end of that scene but um and yeah
integrity is um it's a
challenging
thing and i value it much and i think
um
it can take 20 years to build a
reputation in two minutes to lose it and
there is nothing more that i value than
but integrity and
you know if i'm ever wrong about
anything i truly don't want to be
wrong for any longer than i have to be
um
you know that's what being in some ways
a scientist is you're
you're just driven by truth and the
irony relative to something like
mathematics is that in science you never
find truth what all you do in science is
you discount the things that are likely
to be untrue
leaving only the possibility of what
could be true yeah but in math
you know when you create
you know a proof it's a proof for you
know
from that point forward there is truth
in mathematics and there's i think
there's a beauty in that but i kind of
like the messiness of of science because
again
to me it's less about the truth of the
answer and it is more about the pursuit
of questions but their integrity becomes
more and more important and it becomes
more difficult there's a lot of
pressures just like in the rest of the
world but
there's a lot of pressures on a
scientist uh one is like funding sources
yeah i've noticed this that um you know
money affects everyone's mind i think
um i've been always somebody that
i believe money can't you can't buy
my opinion uh i don't care how much
money billions or trillions
the
but that pressure is there and you have
to be very cognizant of it and make sure
that
your opinion is not defined by the
funding sources
and then the other is just your own
success
of uh you know for a couple of decades
publishing an idea
um
and then realizing at some point that
that idea was wrong all along right and
that that's a tough thing for people to
do but that's also integrity is to walk
away is to say that you were wrong
um
that doesn't have to be in some big
dramatic way it could be in a bunch of
tiny ways along the way right like uh
reconfigure your intuition about a
particular
uh problem
that's and all of that is integrity when
everybody in the room
uh you know believes a certain thing
everybody in the community believes a
certain thing
to uh to be able to still be open-minded
in the face of that
yeah and i think it comes down in some
ways to the issue of ego that you bond
your you know correctness or your
rightness your scientific theory
with your sense of
ego
you know i've never found it that
difficult to let go of
theories in the face of counter evidence
in part because i have such low
self-esteem well i i kind of like that i
always like that combination i have the
same i'm like very self-critical
imposter syndrome all those things
uh putting yourself below the podium but
at the same time having the ego that
drives the ambition to work your ass off
like some kind of weird drive
maybe
like to drive to be better like thinking
yourself is not that great and always
driving to be better and at the same
time because that's that can be
paralyzing and exhausting
and so on at the same time just being
grateful to be alive but in the sciences
in the actual effort
never be satisfied never think of
yourself highly that seems to be a nice
combination i very much hope that that
is part of who i am and i
remain very quietly motivated and driven
and i like you
love the idea of perfection and i know i
will never achieve it but i will never
stop trying to
you